les missions sont là on a supprimé en
soi ne nie qu'il ya du travail à bay
hill tous au chili à la dimension la
world life aux pouvoir ouvrir des
emplois de vrais emplois
faut-il être fier de s'être battus
autant pendant plus de 15 jours
melun vertal doriot faut-il être fiers
de cette battue autant d'avoir mobilisé
autant d'énergie pour de la précarité
oui nous sommes fiers aujourd'hui il
faut bien se rendre compte ce drame
social ont assisté à des collègues
emplois aidés qui pleurait à la veille
de la rentrée
tout simplement parce qu on leur
enlevait ce contrat ce sont des contrats
de 500 euros de 700 euros
c'est catastrophique c'est honteux et je
le dis solennellement c'est honteux de
la part de l'état d'avoir des missions
qui sont définies dans des
établissements scolaires et de ne pas
assurer un salaire décent
nous avons plus pu permettre à ces
personnes de retrouver une dignité de
relever la tête et de pouvoir dire à la
société
oui moi je travaille ma d'adversité
l'horizon il n'aurait pas fallu taper
beaucoup plus fort sur le top obtenir
plus tout de suite ce fut extrêmement
compliqué je suppose quand même que vous
le savez à quel point ce fut compliqué
aujourd'hui bien évidemment que ce ne
sont pas des emplois pérennes mais au
moins sa dignité qu a été retrouvé par
un l'ensemble de ses collègues
ben nous sommes fiers de ça on s'est
battu pour eux on s'est battu avec eux
lorsqu'ils étaient aussi dans la rue
avec nous et oui nous sommes fiers de
cette mobilisation
et ça donne aussi une nouvelle image aux
organisations syndicales
parce que on en a beaucoup tapé un sur
les organisations syndicales que ça
servait à rien etc
nous allons aujourd'hui vous savez
pourquoi oui parce qu'il ya aussi le
souvenir de 2009 qui est extrêmement
compliqué dans notre histoire
martiniquaise
mais aujourd'hui on peut dire une
organisation syndicale ça sert à quelque
chose
la sacem le threesome vous avez
l'impression qu'on n'était pas si loin
que ça de nouveau février 2009 à travers
cette mobilisation
on n'était pas si loin que ça et on l'a
dit plusieurs fois monsieur le préfet
qu'il prendrait la responsabilité si
paris n'était pas capable d'entendre la
grogne qui monte est partout
sur l'a6 étudiera notre micro il a
manifesté son inquiétude mais il me
semble que paris n'a pas suffisamment
entendue cette inquiétude et c'est une
question aussi que l'endroit se poser
alors comment faire justement pour que
paris ressentent entièrement totalement
cette inquiétude
ça c'est le boulot des politiques des
parlementaires aujourd'hui c'est
certainement la boule au départ
politiques et des parlementaires
mais il faut se dire aujourd'hui que
nous avons fait plier paris votre
mouvement relayé par les centrales par
les associations par les élus par les
parents par même les scolaires a fait
des mécontents
yan monplaisir qu'il est par exemple le
président de la commission développement
économique et tourisme de l'astral et de
martinique a parlé je vais le site et
d'irresponsabilité en bloquant les
routes de prise en otage de ceux qui
veulent travailler de comportement
jusqu'au boutiste pour flatter l'égo
d'une poignée d'agitateurs
il a parlé également de climat subversif
vous répondez quoi ah yan monplaisir
je lui répond tout de go que je suis
fier d'avoir agité mon peuple
martiniquais pour sa dignité
je lui réponds aussi qu'il n'a
strictement rien compris à ce qui était
la précarité
1 quand on est précaire quand on a du
mal à nourrir sa famille on se rend on
comprend ce combat syndical de chef
d'entreprise que c'est ce que s'est
accru de l'emploi il sait ce que c'est
mais monsieur montplaisir travaille
aussi beaucoup avec des associations qui
emploient des contrats aidés
1 dans le cadre de ces deux de ses
missions de chef d'entreprise
moi je dis qu'il n'a rien compris à ce
qui était la martinique et je
m'arrêterai là concernant ça je préfère
voir vous ne le positif on a gagné pas
sa rencontre pour lui expliquer cette
réalité ça ne m'intéresse pas cette
grève à propos des contrées des plus
largement mis en avant cette vive
tension dans notre île cette tension
liée à cette fragilité sociale au
chômage pouvoir d'achat la précarité
il faut faudra que les organisations
syndicales continuent à se battre pour
pour lutter contre tout cela il faut
savoir que les organisations syndicales
se bat tous les jours dans le secteur
killer qui les concerne tous les jours
on se bat contre la précarité
on se bat pour pouvoir avoir des salles
et à l'impression des fois que les
collègues ne réalisent pas à quel point
tous les jours on est sollicité par ici
par le rectorat puisque c'est
ce sont les collègues de l'éducation
nationale que je représente pour pouvoir
améliorer le système
on se bat tous les jours et on
continuera à se battre et j'espère
vraiment profondément que cette lutte a
permis aux martiniquais de retrouver la
confiance dans leur organisation qui
sont des personnes qui freinent cette
amélioration de de cette société tout
simplement
c'est certainement ce qui sont à la tête
des bourses de l'état déjà et qui
veulent rentrer dans leur célèbre 3% de
déficit
je crois que on doit avoir des objectifs
aussi des objectifs sociaux la société a
changé
on doit aussi permettre à l'ensemble il
faut donner un véritable sens sa liberté
égalité fraternité
ouais un égal et émeutiers 4000 dans les
rues de fort de france alors 4000 ce
sont les chiffres des rg donc ça veut
dire que c'est beaucoup plus un oui on
s'est beaucoup parce qu'il a 3000
contrats aidés oui mais 12 il y a aussi
les enseignants il ya des associations
c'est vraiment l'impression que la
population martiniquaise a fait peuple
avec cette cause oui j'en suis persuadé
il ya bien évidemment des insatisfaits
cependant moi aussi j'ai écouté la radio
où vous aviez certain nombre d' échanges
avec des gens qui appelaient sur votre
robot radio et beaucoup comprenez c'est
vrai que nous avons choisi des méthodes
d'action qui font que une partie de la
sauce de la population a été à un moment
un petit peu agacé de notre mouvement
mais dans ce pays si on ne bloque pas
tout à fait les choses n'avancent pas si
on ne montre pas qu'on a cette capacité
de mobilisation et qu'on a cette
capacité de gêner mais aussi de gêner
les entreprises ans et c'est pour ça que
monsieur montplaisir a eu sa sortie bien
malheureux je pense que aujourd'hui il
comprend à quel point c'est ridicule ce
qui l'a sorti mais aujourd'hui si on ne
bloque pas tout ça marche pas mais je
crois que beaucoup de gens ont compris
la cause dans chaque famille
martiniquaise il y a un il y a deux il
ya des fois cinq contrats aidés et je
crois que beaucoup de personnes nous ont
compris et pourquoi cette question des
contrats aidés ne fait pas plus de bruit
que cela ailleurs davantage
abbas et je viens de recevoir des mails
de mon organisation syndicale nationale
il faut savoir que dans beaucoup de deux
d'établissement dans des académies
françaises aussi abeilles il ya de plus
en plus de manifestations contre la
suppression des emplois aidés morte ce
décret montre le chemin
la montée
martinez qu'a montré le chemin merci
valérie vertal loriot au d'avoir dit ce
matin avec nos dents sortait bien
rappelle que vous êtes membre de l'unité
syndicale et associative qui avait été
qui était en lutte pour le maintien des
contrats et des re martinique merci
bonne journée
merci
[Musique]